le canard en fête ses 50 ans depuis sa
création en 1965 l'organisme de mobilité
a permis à des milliers de réunionnais
de sauter la mer désormais la mobilité
s'inscrit dans un parcours d'excellence
une préparation départ pour permettre
d'envoyer les plus motivés tenter leur
chance et trouver du travail dans
l'hexagone et en 1983 d'un conseil
général prendre une décision importante
celle de faciliter la mobilité pour de
l'emploi en métropole
à ce moment la collectivité décide de
confier au renard la mise en place d'un
service entre la réunion et la métropole
pour favoriser cette fois non plus comme
ce moment mais aussi des départs dès 50
ans est un âge avancé un bilan était
nécessaire ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que
l'institution a évolué tant dans ces
métiers que dans ces dispositifs que
dans sa manière de travailler
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur des
dispositifs novateurs avec l'alternance
nous sommes maintenant sur l'ouverture à
l'international nous sommes sur plus de
professionnalisme au niveau des actions
de préparation a invité sur un
accompagnement qui est beaucoup plus
pointues en métropole donc une vieille
dame qui se porte bien qu'ils se
rendaient en costaud les jours depuis
2007 plusieurs conventions de
partenariat ont été signées avec des
organismes tels que la mission locale le
pôle emploi le rsm a ou encore la
chambre des métiers
le cncc développe différents dispositifs
pour accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi
parmi ces dispositifs le contrat
d'apprentissage et le contrat
d'alternance rencontre un vif succès le
groupe casino disney ou encore monoprix
permettent à des jeunes de se former
tout en préparant son diplôme sur ce
partenariat
ce qui ce qui frappe c'est dans un
premier temps tout ce qui concerne la
présélection des candidats puisque
aujourd'hui
en fait nous recrute essentiellement sur
de l'alternance et donc quand on veut en
recruter
ici les candidats savent déjà pour
quelles entreprises savent déjà sur quel
métier et du coup on a des taux en fait
dans gauche qui sont très satisfaisants
aujourd'hui puisqu'on est aux alentours
de 60 70 % une centaine d'entreprises
partenaires permettent toujours dû à
deux jeunes réunionnais de signer un cdd
ou encore un cdi cédric a eu un parcours
exemplaire son courage à payer
aujourd'hui il a décroché un cdi sa mère
témoigne
il a eu son bac pro qui a eu son bac pro
et puis pas de place ici en bts pour lui
parce que avec 13 95 moyenne
la mention assez bien mais pas mention
bien et pour avoir une mention pour être
au lycée il faut avoir un bébé s mention
bien et donc panique à bord
on ne sait pas on est au mois de juillet
on sait pas comment les choses vont se
dérouler donc je me retournais le cnam
et là ils ont juste été je trouve pas de
mots pour cela puisque l'accompagnement
effectivement il ya eu d'accompagnement
financières c'est une bonne chose il ya
l'accompagnement une fois qu'on en
arrive là bas sur site
jérôme peut aussi se féliciter de sa
progression professionnelle cet
autodidacte a trouvé dans la mobilité la
force de réussir tu es responsable
d'opérations en sueur et peinture et
avec une équipe d'aujourd'hui 400
personnes sont en responsabilité pour
schématiser un petit peu tout ça un
directeur général et moi avec tout
l'équipement
en complément et sachant que l'homme a
commencé en tant qu agent d'exploitation
c'est-à-dire vraiment en bas de
l'échelle et c'est à france 2 d'être
présent de rien refuser
et toujours de proposer ça au service
que petit à petit
entre ces consciences et exigence rival
en 2014 ce sont 2000 37 réunionnais qui
ont pris la destination de la france
métropolitaine 25% ont fait l'objet d'un
contrat par alternance
désormais l'objectif fixé de 5000 départ
pour permettre au plus grand nombre de
profiter de la mobilité une opportunité
professionnelle avec au bout l'espoir
pour ceux qui en rêvent de revenir un
jour travailler au pays